[Music]
this
is star talk sports edition
cosmic queries got with me chuck knight
co-host
what's happening good to have jack
always a pleasure yeah this is sports
edition and and you're not an
athlete so just to make that clear
to the audience i am sometimes when i'm
sleeping
sometimes you wake up after you've won
the gold medal right now they put the
metal around my neck and then i wake up
like
oh damn gary o'reilly gary
hey my other co-host in this which uh
is the legit street cred part of this
triad here
chuck i still have that dream by the way
there's still no gold medal but you know
what
you got to have a dream so so gary when
were you
playing professional soccer in the uk i
spanned three decades
so seriously yeah i am that old um
the 70s late part of the 70s and
moved through into the early part of the
90s so i made my professional debut
at a rather famous club tottenham
hotspur in london
at the age of 19. okay cool yeah and um
but you're still an old fart absolutely
totally
decrepid old fart
so today in this cosmic queries we're
going to do
the physics of sports and you know i i
try to wax poetic about that often in my
social media but
to really do it right we had to reach
into
our rolodex and find our resident geek
in chief
and chuck you know who that is there's
only one person
only one person there's only one and
that's charles liu
hey hi neal gary chuck it's so good to
see you again hello hello
welcome back to star talk chuck isn't
charles
i start chuck whichever can also go by
chuck but
we have two chucks i'm going with
charles charles is an old friend a
co-author
a colleague and so we go way back
and he just started a new rock band
yeah i hadn't heard well i'm just
judging by your hand
yes i'm conducting a scientific
experiment what will happen
to my facial expression if i don't cut
my hair for a year
yeah yes the covid haircut that the
non-hair very excited
well you know if you develop superhuman
strength stay away from any woman with
scissors that's all i'm saying
the record shows well you know what my
my brother-in-law
saw me for the first time on zoom in
quite some time a few weeks ago and he
said
that still counts as a midlife crisis
growing your hair long
oh yeah interesting oh and one one thing
about
uh that story with cutting your hair so
do you know who cut samson's hair
uh not the life was it delilah or it
wasn't it yes
[Laughter]
because you know if samson doesn't look
good he doesn't look good
and just just show it to him but anyhow
so so charles
yes i just you are on this program
because
however geeky anybody is there's always
someone on the geek spectrum
geekier than than than you think you are
right so you are the geekiest person
we've ever had on this show
and so you represent that that extreme
limit the way we need binoculars to find
where you are on that scale you are the
supernova
of geekitude you are all kind beyond
kind thank you but uh i would just once
uh
love to be able to score that winning
goal the same way that gary has and
chuck has in his dreams all these years
oh okay okay so you all do it in
different ways charles
yeah so let me give you a pedigree here
so you're professor
of astrophysics the college of staten
island at the city university of new
york
yes and you're an associate at
my hayden planetarium and delighted to
have you on this to my great delight
on our staff there thank you so you're
an associate so it means we we reach for
you when we need you and you
contribute and participate in many of
our uh
excellent programs and they just came
out with the handy
physics answer book coming out like
it came out this year and it's part of
the handy answer book series
and so that's just great i i'm so that
it's that kind of
background that you have not only in
astrophysics but in basic physics that
contributes
to this so so gary you got the first
question i have and this is from
our patreon patrons and we are
we are lovely with them and right this
is
since most sports contain some degree of
probability or
chance i wonder if a new sport can be
devised that takes into account the
probability presented by something like
and this is going to go way over my head
wave particle duality
because that sounds like a surfboard for
two
but i'm guessing that's my low brained
attitude to this so please
guys you've got to expand so charles
what do you what oh by the way let me
just say
that the sport with some of the least
probability
involved in it is wrestling okay because
you and your muscles against
the your opponent and their air muscles
and it's not did you hit the ball
in the right fraction of an inch or is
the wind going in the right direction
if you if you look if you lose your ass
lost okay
unless for some reason your muscle had a
twitch for no good reason
random twitch quantum mechanically
induced twitch that caused your arm to
suddenly be
pinned behind your back the odds of that
are slim
they force you to just go to your back
for no reason
so so wave particle duality gary is
a fundamental part of quantum theory and
uh a guy named de bruy d-e-b-r-o-g-l-i-e
kind of put together this idea that
matter
can be waves and waves can be matter
william de bruyne he he basically said
and explained that there is this wave
particle duality so
a little particle like an electron
behaves simultaneously
both as a particle something with
negative charge for example
and as a wave so it produces
interference effects and things like
that just as an ocean wave might
in a larger environment uh de bruyne
also
two ocean waves coming through and
hitting each other that's right uh the
odd thing is
that even something large like a
baseball or a soccer ball or something
like that
is also a matter wave but the wavelength
is so tiny far smaller than an atomic
nucleus
that we in the macroscopic world will
never notice
those wave effects so in a sense we are
all
waves of matter kind of interacting with
other waves of matter
but with wavelengths so small it's as if
that wave action didn't matter
so if you wanted to use wave particle
duality
to actually have some effect in
a sport you'd have to be on the
microscopic level right i might imagine
someday in the future
where instead of playing video games
like this there might be
a special kind of video game that you
were zooming in
and looking at a tiny subatomic
realm in a sense all right well chuck
let's let's just blow that out
and say fine so let's say in the future
we have such power over the universe
that we can change the value of the
physical constants
and so now i've created within a small
area of the unit no no no no i've
created a quantum stadium
and in that stadium planck's constant is
really large so so you start getting
these
quantum effects with regular everyday
objects and people and phenomenon so
tell me what sport would you devise
that could be like a quantum olympic
entry oh
well okay um not to get extra geeky on
you on this
one if you were to increase planck's
constant to that level you'd also have
massive fluctuations of energy
within that stadium so that at any given
time
something equivalent to a a nuclear
explosion would go off right in front of
one of your players and so
that's why you don't want that's a game
i want to go
so that's so you're saying bad ideas
well i mean
if it were something like car wars or
you know
mad max or something where you have cars
all you're trying to do is get from one
place to the next and random explosions
can be going off in the stadium in any
time see the sport of the future childs
will involve more fan
interaction so if you've got a stadium
meal in your
quantum stadium then all of a sudden
they
shout whilst the offense
is in motion that then becomes something
that derails that offense
by moving it yeah so if you get enough
people uh coordinated in their actions
you can influence the outcome of the
sport well it's already happening on
twitch for example right
so if you have a situation beyond the
video realm into the physical realm
then i would devise a sport kind of
where you would have an object that
could randomly move
and the goal of the team is to grab that
object
or to otherwise obtain this randomly
moving thing
sounds like quidditch
[Laughter]
you are absolutely right so maybe uh
maybe the quidditch pitch is indeed a
quantum stadium just like you described
nice
and the birdie or whatever that's called
that's uh following quantum rules
position what's it called the birdie the
golden snitch
i'm sorry the snitch excuse me the
snitch i do like birdie though that
sounds
so the golden snitch is its position
in three-dimensional four-dimensional
space and time
is quantum determined because they don't
know where it's going now that would be
that case
although presumably in harry potter's
world of wizardry yeah it's not
quantum determined but it's uh magically
determined or even sentiently determined
it's not clear if in fact the gold
snitch is alive i was going to say the
golden snitch may have a consciousness
because
when you look at the way it moves it's
clear it's clearly not random
it's trying to evade the players so you
never know
okay in a quantum world it could pop in
and out of existence which means
it would be even cooler totally cool if
you add it if you had a fourth dimension
if you
entangled the golden snitch yeah
so that it could instantaneously provide
information somewhere else
uh and that would be almost like
teleportation
right so it could just like be in one
part of the stadium and then when you go
to reach it
it's gone and then it's over there now
all right that'd be kind of cool
hope that's your answer
how deep does this rabbit hole go oh man
let's find out
okay now if i if i can add an addendum
to this if i may charles
uh in recent years uh was it uh who's
the guy who plays ant-man
um oh scott lang paul rudd
paul rudd i think collaborated with
stephen hawking to create quant the
rules for quantum chess
where when you try to take a piece
there's a probability that that piece is
a different piece
or is not even there and so you're
judging what the likelihood is of the
success of that move will be
at every time you make a move so you can
google it quantum chess it's pretty good
season two of queen's gambit right there
well let's not get into ant-man and and
quantum stuff because that's a whole
nother
someone might as well yeah let's let's
get to the to the
questions okay okay
all right so chuck you're next yeah did
you finally reboot your
your ipad i rebooted my my little ipad
and so i'm good now okay so
um this is from uh uh violeta she's
12 years old oh fabulous
yes and uh she has a story that's too
long to read but thank you for the story
uh oh by the way by the way just a quick
thing um
violet i guess is little violet right so
um
you know the rhyme roses are red so
every five years i tweet
roses are red violets are violent
periods unless you don't have very
strong sensitivity in the ultraviolet or
the body yeah
i'm not trying to actually look blue the
tweet is not intended
for people for charles liu
i'm wearing blue blocker glasses right
right you be blocking glasses
okay so what does violetta have to say
she's 12 years old very good okay
and uh she's she's she basically says
wait a minute is she a patreon member
wait a minute yes her mom is it's
violetta and
mom and mom okay isn't it good and mom
is a patreon member and
uh for for that we say thanks for the
money yes
um it's thanks for your support
oh i'm sorry well you know see that's
i know now i'm giving myself away
because people are just like i support
you i'm like i don't need your support i
want your money
that reminds me of pearl bailey once
said during uh
primarily old singer actors
uh she said on
on valentine's day uh honey on
valentine's day i want a
five pound box of money
[Laughter]
[Music]
you all know the beatles song money
right yes yeah
right money can't buy everything is true
but whatever i i can't use
i need your money that's what i did
all together
all right so here's violet she says
she's never heard of the beatles or
pearl bailey i'll bet she has
well she has now this is great um
uh she's talking about stem and to her
stem should be stem
with a b on the end that is silent that
stands for baseball
yes chuckle who's excited about that
what a sport
uh so science uh tech engineering math
and
baseball and and she says this dr lou
i am wondering as far as the physics
may go are there any skills that you can
think of that might give women a
particular advantage in baseball
maybe like rather than trying to throw
the fast pitch developing interesting
off-speed pitches instead
can you think of any other areas of
untapped baseball physics
that players of any gender haven't yet
explored to their fullest potential
i love all the star talk episodes and
having you as a guest
you always are so gracious and your
answers to
questions are fascinating thank you for
being you
signed charles blue's mom
does say and in all modesty i
and she's talking about i play baseball
and i'm just saying
i'm pretty good oh yeah i forgot to
start out i'm back
good for you love that violet and izzy
thank you so much for the question thank
you for your kind words it's very sweet
uh baseball is a tremendous sport and it
is a wonderful way to learn stem
actually there's so many intricacies of
it and
so much of it requires scientific
understanding
uh not just hitting home runs right but
your question is very very good
people have this preconceived notion
that you have to have a certain body
type or certain
way of playing individual sports and for
baseball that's one of the sports where
any kind of body type or any kind of
thing uh that you can bring to the table
that's unique
can help you stand out exhibiting babe
ruth
body built on beer and hot dogs
yes uh so i would say for example if
you're looking for a typical female uh
physique uh yes your pitching uh will
allow you
uh you might be able to have unusual
pitches uh because you're able to have
the ball
leave your hand or your whole arm
structure in a different way
if you're running the bases for example
you may be able to
through flexibility or through other
kinds of training be able to
dodge uh tags if you're trying to steal
a base
or you might be able to leap in the
field uh find certain ways to
grab things and throw better so chuck
this would be a flexibility that
women tend to enjoy in more
ways than men do that's true
that's right and also things like so for
throwing a ball for example your fingers
and then of course uh there's the strike
zone right
uh the strike zone is supposedly from
your shoulders to your knees
so it doesn't matter how big or how
small you are if you're able to reach a
ball in the strike zone it's always
going to be
roughly a level playing field and in
some senses uh for example
except for where the pitching mound is
that's right right there
well
[Laughter]
chuck you're i'm trying to be do put
jokes in here and where are you
but yeah you know that's that's i mean
you're you're talking about field
technicalities that's right
well the the mound was lowered in the
60s because
it is ridiculous that's because of bob
gibson's ridiculous 1.12 era back
when he was pitching for the cardinals
that year but yeah so uh
they're very famous uh players who have
such good crouches that their strike
zones were small and it gave them an
advantage in hitting
so it may well be the case that you can
take advantage of that if your body type
or your physique uh matches that of
the uh and how about a woman's lower
center of gravity
would that come into play in any way
shape or form in baseball
i can only imagine that if you're trying
to field a hot ground ball to third base
or something like that
that you might be able to move laterally
more effectively
than someone whose body mass is more
weighted toward the top because you have
to move
more of your mass a larger distance in
order to go sideways
charles would that not help with hitting
a lower centering center of gravity
where you were able to get
under a pitch and hit it ah right well
uh in baseball uh most hitters are
taught not to get under the ball
to try to lift the ball fly ball but
rather hit the ball levelly
you just want to make contact right and
have strong level contact so yes
if you're lower and a pitcher can't
quite get the ball
down or is trying to get the ball down
so that you only hit ground balls you
may be able
to be more flexible either with your
crouch or just have a smaller height
to be able to hit the ball where you
want it to go because you have a better
opportunity to pick off the ball
before it does its break or before it
gets too low and people with famously
high
lifetime batting averages were not
statistically larger than your average
baseball players i mean
yeah maybe the best example is wade
boggs
who was famous for having a low crouch
and his lifetime batting average was
tremendous
then one year he decided to prove to
people that he could actually hit
the long ball also because he was tired
of people saying yeah all you do is hit
line drives
having a great year hitting home runs so
he just proved
that and also with the lower center of
mass not all
plays at the plate is the ball exactly
where it needs to be for the tag
so the catcher will have to catch it and
then move lower to a lower position
and so if you're already down there that
could give you a few extra scoring
opportunities because of that but
excellent chuck
we got to take a quick we got to take a
quick break when we come back more star
trek cosmic queries
the physics of sports on star talk
we're back star talk sports edition
cosmic queries the physics
of sport love that subject and gary and
chuck are giving us questions from our
fan base and handing them to our
resident geek in chief friend and
colleague charles liu
nice hi all right i'll jump in right
this one
uh another one of our patreon patrons
cameron bishop
um hi guys i have a question about
motorsports specifically formula one
uh how oh charles is already excited how
would we need to adapt our cars which
are already very complicated
engineering feats for a grand prix
hosted somewhere
like mars well first you have to make
sure that lewis hamilton is wearing a
helmet
uh otherwise he won't be able to breathe
very well beyond that
formula one it has primarily
improved car performance over the years
by becoming more and more aerodynamic
right right they're using airplane
technology to make sure that the cars
actually stay on the road better that
they can turn corners better and just go
faster
so the car the car is flying in reverse
literally yes
it's flying in reverse it's a really
good way to say it the problem is of
course
mars wait charles i think the future of
portland should be rocket engines i'm
sorry that's just
that's just me you know solid rocket
boosters nasa should sponsor
formula one and strap on some srb and
then it wins every time
here's here's the the cornering is the
problem gary is exactly what he's gonna
say
because it's not a drag race right this
actually requires some
some skill and finesse here so here's
here's the first
post race interview at the meals
after neil's thing it's like so it was
an interesting experiment
uh what are those what are all those
marks on the wall
yeah those those are the cars
where the cars hit no those are the
actual cars
can you imagine a rocket powered formula
one grand prix in monte carlo
oh my god i'm sticking out of buildings
oh that'd be terrible yeah i got to work
on that detail
but you're on to something new because
because for example on mars
the atmospheric pressure is less than
one percent that of
the atmospheric pressure here on earth
so uh internal combustion engines
wouldn't work
so you would have to have something like
a rocket so what you're trying to do is
you need
you need some device that will
steal more air from its surroundings
than would otherwise be
naturally fed to the engine
that is the actual propulsion it's the
induction of air
and then the combustion out the battery
in the cavity that then sends it out the
best right right so okay that means
and then and so that way a rocket engine
might actually be the best solution so
you can avoid the issue of atmosphere
altogether because
after all most of the atmosphere in mars
is carbon dioxide which won't help you
with a jet engine as we understand them
anyway
right looting effect in the environment
we haven't done that
good a job here we can now go export
that to mars
it would be an environmental disaster i
agree
fabulous let's do that then yeah but
then cars would not need to be nearly so
aerodynamic either so you would have to
focus on control
your ability to stay on the road when
you're going at ridiculous speed that's
fascinating point charles so because the
atmospheric pressure is so low
aerodynamics is you can you could have
like you don't have the resistance
yeah you don't need air foils and and
funny
funky shapes it would be a one percent
effect as opposed to much larger
we'd be racing mercedes g wagons which
have been
which we have the aerodynamics of a
brick
a box yeah you you would not have to
worry about the shape of your vehicle
nearly so much you want instead to know
the shape would be depending on whether
or not you can grip the road whether you
can make the turns at very high speeds
and things like that some of the physics
is very similar you want a low center of
gravity
you want good traction things like that
but the power ratio compared with the uh
shape structure would be very different
but so charles if you're
uh because the gravity is less is like
40 of earth's gravity
does that affect the slope of the bank
turns if you have a bank turn at all it
would
i'm thinking nascar really there yes
because you have bank turns but um
remember that
the issue of your angular momentum is
more important when you're going very
high speed than the gravitational pull
right
because your gravity you you're going to
their car is literally going to be like
the sand in a
bucket that is being swung up and down
at the beach
you're you're going to stay on
regardless of whether or not you have
the gravity pulling on you because your
angular momentum
is so much greater okay so yes if i go
up a hill at 200 plus miles per hour on
mars
am i likely to stay on the ground once i
reach the peak or have i
gone i want to say airborne but that's
not quite you want to go into orbit gary
is that what you're trying to do no i'm
just going to say how do i
how are we working that out in terms of
avoiding immediately
if i were to do the physics real quick
uh in my head
um 200 miles an hour you would fly off
yes you'd have to be almost vertical
in order not to fly off you'd still rise
quite up high
so the race would have to be slower uh
the race would be slower or the slopes
would have to be higher if you're
banking your curves right
one way or the other think about olympus
mons right the the tallest volcano on
mars
uh that thing is many times taller than
mount everest
because the gravitational uh
acceleration at the surface of mars is
lower than that on earth so these
mountains can rise higher
so that's what you'd have to do with the
banks the race to the top of
uh that volcano that would be something
that's that that's uh that's a grand
prix uh for sure all right
yeah all right all right cool man all
right okay
let's uh let's move on to let me just
add to
follow up quickly on chuck's point this
reason why
the the the combustion engines have
trouble is the same reason why regular
airplanes there's a limit to how high
they can fly
right at any given speed because they
have to suck enough air to make that
the jet engine phenomenon work so
yeah we take so much for granted down
here at sea level
of what's going on all right super cool
uh
and yeah okay uh so planes can be like
icarus is what you're saying
well but instead of being burned by the
sun they run out of there
yeah yeah all right here we go uh this
is ruben was here
and he says how the heck does one throw
a curveball
what physics is going on there uh
rudon wants to know uh i would say
you know what i'm gonna throw this to
gary a little bit because
uh throwing curveball the reason the
ball curves is very similar to the
reason a soccer ball curves when it gets
kicked
and and so uh i want
the uh true athlete to sort of explain
why the ball curves and then i can bring
on the physics for the
the baseball in particular you mean you
want gary to say what he has to do to
make the ball curve
yes exactly you'll give the physics of
that so gary i would like to do okay
um first of all gary why would you want
to curve a soccer ball what you want to
do is
no no so okay in a certain time
um i want to disable the say the goal
goalkeeper the goalminder and have them
think the ball is going from left to
right
and therefore they move that way and
then the ball just comes back in
from right to left oh so they're
committing their body momentum in the
role
so once i get the body weight loaded to
one side in particular it's going to be
very difficult for them to
yeah that's just wrong that's just not
nice hence my prefix of
this is devious and when it works do you
go haha treacher
okay oh absolutely
yeah and i mean that's another thing is
the route to gold may be blocked you see
this in
free kicks yeah where they build a wall
to protect the goal and then all of a
sudden someone and then they use their
hands to protect their private parts
of course yeah i mean themselves one
must protect the crown jewels at all
times
right so um and the most famous
free kick in recent times was roberto
carlos
against france i think it's 97 france
versus brazil
or brazil versus france 1997 is recent
times
that's 23 years ago yeah i think how old
are you
um i'm a thousand years old 25 years ago
i remember that goal yeah it was it was
ridiculous yeah yeah in in answer to
your question neil you can carbon date
me after the show and
their answer um so roberto carlos comes
up to the ball
outside of his left foot he's now
addressing he's coming up to the ball
addressing the ball on the right hand
side so is he going to kick it with his
left foot he hits it
on the outside of the
ball on the right hand side now if you
imagine the ball has an
imaginary equator he's got to hit right
on that equatorial
point but in towards the slightly more
into the middle so he can get
power to make it travel the distance
but because he hits across it he imparts
this spin this rotation
and you can see from a camera behind the
ball
it deviates by about two
yards or more it is going wide of the
goal
and then all of a sudden it cuts back in
in the most vicious
way the goalkeeper is a world cup
winning goalkeeper
uh bartes who
uh if you can imagine this looks a
little bit like the the
old hollywood actor donald pleasence
who was a bond villain if i'm not
mistaken there you go but more famously
for being i think it was cindy
crawford's partner at some stage there
you go there's your
there's your sad nugget of information
not sad for donald pleasance
so charles we were taught you can't hit
too fine
you have to make contact in the meat of
the ball but if you hit lower
the ball will spin and rise if you kind
of hit across that equatorial plane
it will stay in a lower trajectory and
travel
and you'll make more contact with the
ball and therefore
impart more power and force through the
ball okay so if you
if you kick it on the right side giving
it kind of like
from the top a counterclockwise spin
you'll then veer left
yes okay and and you will i angle your
run to approach it so as you
you really do slice across it but with
such power
and this is 30 yards there's a trade-off
between
maximizing the spin by hitting it just
at the outer edge and giving putting
some meat on the kick
to have the thing move forward so
charles this is why i guess
uh curve balls are never as fast as fast
balls
correct because so some of the answers
are exactly right the picture is using
is going to spin it
you are 100 correct and gary thank you
that was just a an excellent explanation
was going you're welcome
yeah from the recent goal
23 years ago but still most likely
immortal
uh one of the most amazing goals ever uh
except maybe the 86 diego maradona goal
in the world cup but
that didn't have as much to do with that
was against england so we do not
yes but that was not as much
aerodynamics as just
ridiculous skill but that's a that's
another story
uh and then there was the hands go ahead
of that but let's let that aside as you
said
it was against england okay
the curveball requires that the pitcher
push the ball a little bit sideways as
it's being thrown giving it a twist
and not pushing it straight on as hard
as you can right in the middle
uh because the baseball like the soccer
ball is not a perfect sphere
it can then interact as it spins with
the air that it
encounters on the way to the plate it's
not that the ball is oblong
you mean the surfaces textures the
surface is never so
it's not a perfectly smooth sphere it's
textured yeah that's right that's the
right way to put it
and so as a result you can create the
curve action now with a baseball it's
considered a rigid body
right it doesn't change its shape nearly
as much as a soccer ball does so when
you
hit the ball the soccer ball uh the
deformation
of the soccer ball provides an even
greater change which is why you can have
this
sort of l-shaped turn with the curveball
just kind of get a little bit of a
kind of thing that's a different scale
of motion and also the distances are
so what's happening with the forces on
the ball with the air and the forces
you have the spin which is creating uh
non-laminar flow around the ball
and then the laces of the baseball uh
accentuate that point so the more you
spin it the more likely is going to
happen if you had a perfectly smooth
uniform
baseball then the ball may not curve
no matter how much spin you put on it
because there isn't the opportunity to
disturb the air
so when you disturb the air it creates
an unequal force left and right on the
ball
right or up and down for that matter or
up and down right and all of that
movement matters
the sinking or the rising fastball will
do that's right
so another level of deviousness for the
soccer player
and it's it's all about deviousness a
baseball is a solid object
a soccer ball is inflated i know you're
ahead of me on this
but the aperture in which you inflate
the ball if you strike through that
you then have charles and my right some
sort of pressure change and you have a
definite
impact honey intended on the defamation
of the ball
and it will knuckle as a baseball pitch
that's right
so so when you see people setting up the
soccer ball for a penalty kick or a free
kick
you always notice that the place where
you stick the inflating pin in is
somewhere where
is the somewhere where the player can
actually hit it with the foot yeah it's
pretty amazing and the most devious
thing
is in baseball if the pitcher actually
cuts the ball towards the plate or spits
on it
spits on it remember remember the
spitball well yeah
i don't know if you were around back
then but uh the gary surely was yeah
thank you but let's be super harsh now
um the last baseball pitcher in the
major leagues who was allowed to throw
a spitball i believe was satchel paige
because everyone who used to throw spit
balls were grandfathered in and allowed
to do it thereafter
if you put water on the ball and then
you throw it
with whatever spin you have you even
create even more change because that
changes
the aerodynamics it changes the ability
for the ball to go through like
what's slippery and what's not you also
create water that kind of comes out
it changes the trajectory it was spit
balls are ridiculous they're terrible
and then you try to hit the ball
the ball hits the bat and it balls
slippery so it's going to go swirling a
little right so there's a spitball
and then there's the hakkalugi ball yeah
the blob of stuff coming right and the
batter is like oh
look at that just goes right now
[Laughter]
wow guys we gotta cut that for our
second and final break and when we come
back we'll have more star talks sports
edition
cosmic queries the physics of sports
we're back star talk sports edition
cosmic queries the
physics of sports and the one and only
charles liu our resident you can choose
a resident whatever i am who's got the
next question for charles
uh here it is this is from stephen
summers he's a patreon patron and he
wants to know this
uh greetings doctors uh
of space comedy uh question for you
hey
[Laughter]
uh he says questions for dr little i'm
involved in high in a high stakes game
of dumb jot later today
against some nasty uh
uh maybe not nausicans nausicans
yeah yeah yeah not to be confused with
sausages
now i need an edge he says any
recommendations should i turn off the
graph plating
or create a spatial anomaly or just keep
my
phaser set to extra crispy
wait what the hell okay okay what the
hell was that what a great question
what was that what was that dom jot dom
jot is a game
in the star trek next generation deep
space nine uh
universe okay which is some sort of a
mix between
uh pool and pinball
okay uh it was introduced in star trek
uh next generation season seven episode
tapestry
which is kind of like uh it's a
wonderful place why do you know this
yes he's a geek
for charles but in this episode yes
uh jean-luc picard played by patrick
stewart it's kind of like jimmy stewart
and it's a one
sort of lives his past as if he were
able to make different decisions and so
forth
but in that uh the the nausicans are
a bunch of really you know big looking
scary looking thugs uh
and they want to play dom john
dom john you know play human play dom
jump and so they're playing this time
but they cheated and so
yeah so uh he was cheating too and
it's all kinds of funny things like that
so so let me just answer very quickly
uh it's a great question but i would
never countenance anyone trying to stack
the deck and cheat
especially against some angry nausicans
because
they will rip off your appendages if
they get that angry
so i would say to try to play and beat
them fair and square it is well known
that nausicaans
always try to roll the tarik into
straight nines
they always want that because it's like
considered a cool
thing for them way beyond the uh
importance of it in the game
so i knew that i knew that trump you
know that too right yeah without a doubt
so play to block nausicans attempts
to roll the tarik into straight nines
and they will take silly risks which
will then allow you to sort of piecemeal
win this game uh now okay be sure
however
if you're careful uh if you're playing
for example on deep space nine
in quarks make sure that odo is there to
provide enough security so that the
noxicans
do not rip off your appendages and
here's the real answer
be sure not to ask this question if you
don't have a girlfriend
because what you need to what you need
to do is go get a girlfriend first
and then you can ask this kind of
question okay
see that's that's the real answer
you better have a girlfriend is the
answer to this question
i suspect that question and answer might
help attract
a girlfriend yeah unfortunately only
female nausicans will be attracted to
that question
okay so stephen you you had the choice
of two answers
all right let's move on what do you got
all right let's do we gotta do lightning
round
the minimal so charles give me like
sound bite answers okay
here's a question from the minimalistic
soul how to get strength
back with minimal efforts i'll answer
this one take steroids next
[Laughter]
real answer yeah yes go ahead strength
uh repetition
uh of different muscle groups at various
lengths and long periods over long
periods of time
cool as the training regimen as a
training regimen yes yes
so that when you actually are called to
task on that you will recover
more quickly correct yes okay all right
all right
here we go next question this is andrew
gundro
gun drill he said it chuck if you
pronounce it like
gumbo you got it dead on t
here we go so he says he says hey guys
uh a common criticism for the
introduction of science into sports is
that it can take away from the soul of
the game
potentially ruining the challenge faced
by the athletes
and the enjoying experienced by the fans
how should we evaluate whether the
introduction of science or data or a.i
will be truly good for the overall sport
or whether it will improve individual
players performance
but ruin the overall gain so when does
it when does it make the game better and
more enjoyable
and when does it detract from the
enjoyment by making the game better
sound bite answer charles this is the
lightning round question
and show all work compare and contrast
here's the sound bite answer the more
science
makes a game or sport fun
the more it's good if you try to put
anything
into a sport or a game that makes it
less fun
whether it's you know steroids or
unfortunate training
or whatever or science it'll make it
less fun
but if we can add the science and say
look this makes the game more fun
which science does if you do it right
then we have no problem
okay i'll give you the answer the
athlete's answer is this
does this give me an advantage can i win
let's have it
yeah i'm in for winning
well there you go okay we're all of the
age when we remembered when the
electronic i think ibm was the first to
do with the electronic tracking of
whether a tennis ball
hits the line or out all right that's
science
applied to a sport did that make it more
or less fun
i think it made it more fun unless
you're yvonne lendl or john mcenroe
right then i'm arguing yeah right well
that's
so funny john mcenroe nowadays would be
he
what are you what are you blind what
shut up john
shut up the computer said it's out
that's like yeah yeah i may be blind but
the computer isn't so get the hell back
though
no okay all right um next this question
is from stay
punk chewball uh how did pro basketball
from what from what uh this is instagram
sorry
uh okay stay punctual how do pro
basketball players have
muscle memory or to make seemingly
impossible shots
well i would say that's probably
practice practice practice
muscle memory is a thing although it's
not
physically a thing so much your brain
actually can pattern in
things that it's done before whether
it's in sports or in
arts or music or science or anything
like that so if you do it
over and over enough times then your
body
knows at that moment what to do what
combination of signals to send
from your brain to your body to get
those things to happen and then uh
there's also the point where you have
improvisation if you have different
sequences in your head already set you
know how to take a shot and you know how
to spin
and you know how to dunk then you can
combine them together
if your brain has done it often enough
almost instantaneously
to a jump and a spin and a dunk all in
sequence cool so what you're saying is
i don't have to invent a new sequence i
just have to staple together other
fragments of the sequence that i've
already perfected
and to everyone else to look like it's
something new well that's my
understanding of the sports physics of
the brain
but you know new new understanding about
how our brains and our bodies work
is coming every day so i may be already
way behind
on the curve cool and like that scene
where uh
where uh michael jordan is at the at the
foul line and he just closes his eyes
and shoots
yeah then it's it's a complete it's all
net
that i would call that muscle memory
yeah
or magic one or the other all right
let's keep this going we're in lightning
round go here we go
get a patreon one this is tyson liu 2019
oh interesting oh wow so he says uh
hockey skates blade contact are we
actually on the ice
or are we on a layer of water what is it
um
good question uh it turns out that it's
complicated it can be either or both
there's been a long uh held belief
that the reason you wind up being able
to skate is because temporarily the ice
skate pushes against the ice
and creates a thin layer of water as it
goes by
but it's more complicated than that if
you do the physics that
alone usually isn't enough so surface
physics
is a part of physics which we haven't
done a really good job in understanding
the models thereof
so it's a combination of solid on solid
and liquid on solid
and that's why uh it's such a dicey
thing to do when you're playing hockey
or where you're doing figure skating
it's not always the same physics that's
causing your skate to move
and therefore you have to adjust
physically with your muscles to make
sure that you're going where you want to
go
wow okay cool all right this is from
instagram jeff
califatt what happens when a basketball
seems to enter
into the hoop but suddenly rolls out
i'll tell you what happens i lose two
hundred dollars
well the ball is always spinning
even if you can't see it on television
so if it hits the rim
it's going to strike at instantaneously
at a particular angle
and there's a spin happening at the same
time it is altogether possible but very
unfortunate for chuck
right that you hit the spin
and the rim in just such a way that the
reflection
angle from that balance is actually out
as opposed to being
in so that's kind of what happens so
charles this is like if i take a ball
and i backspin take a basketball and i
backspin it
away from me if you're just standing and
you don't see the spin it looks like i'm
throwing it away but then it bounces
back towards me
so you can create a bounce trajectory
that's very non-intuitive if you don't
know in advance how the thing is
spinning
that's right okay so so it it can't
go in the net and come out of the net
that that's not the kind of
shot that we're talking about here it's
got to be able the rim is approaching
gotta hit the rim
it's got to hit the hem in order for it
to come back out almost certainly yes
the the
the net is not strong enough stronger
bounce right okay cool man all right
this is
this is diego 93 from instagram i love
this question as somebody who has
tried to serve notice operative word
tried
uh he says what is the force that keeps
you on your surfboard
oh that's not so much force as it is
balance right
equilibrium in order to stay still
in any reference frame in this case the
frame of your board
you have to have all your forces
balanced to zero
in all the other directions otherwise
you tip right
so you're using micro adjustments of
your body your arms your legs your feet
your toes
in such a way right
when i'm surfing that's true
such that if there is a change in the
motion of the board
you are exactly balancing that almost
instantaneously so that relative to the
board
your position and your forces stay
constant
so if you're unfamiliar with surfing it
just looks like they're just
casually balanced but they're saying
there's micro adjustments that i don't
even know incredible muscle power needs
to happen in order for this to go on
uh it is true that that i am told i've
never successfully done this myself
that the the best surfers are one with
their board
yeah which means that they at some point
need to make almost no adjustments
because they intuitively sense where
they need to be at any given time with
the minimum
adjustments necessary to have a zero
net force compared to the position
because if there's any force
that is net that will set the whole
thing into motion and you'll
jump over something you'll spin you'll
fall
wow very cool so cool super surfer
the silver surfer that's the silver one
with the board the silver surfer stayed
on because of the power cosmic given to
him by galactus to be his first herald
but
that again
i set them up you knock them down
fantastic 448 you got to go back to the
to the historical record fantastic
performance
and one thing about the surfer could it
be then that if the surfer
goes on with hand weights that
they would have higher ability to make
adjustments
because they have more weight that they
can maneuver
so that they could survive a
wave action that might otherwise topple
them
like a tightrope artist with a balancing
point for example very good chuck yeah
very possibly i i don't know enough
about the specific physics the
non-linear physics
when you're actually riding a wave to
know whether that's an advantage or a
disadvantage but theoretically that
certainly makes sense
yeah more weight you can reposition that
should give you more that's interesting
but
the future of the future of surfing is
you get two you know barbed two
dumbbells two
stay with this theme okay because cooper
holland has come in on instagram
this might have to be the last question
okay all right it's cool does being
heavier
on skis make you faster
oh fat skiers watch out olympics
let me think about that a little bit on
the one hand a higher mass would cause a
greater normal force which would mean
that you or
if you have a coefficient of friction
that's greater than zero it will slow
you
down going down the slope right on the
other hand
if you have a higher mass uh you may be
able to
tilt yourself a little bit more so that
you have less normal force and more
parallel force heading down
um that's a that's probably uh an
ambiguous
answer but there's also there's also
chuck as you
if you plow through snow going forward
right
you have more more momentum from your
your heavier body
we'll go through that with that because
in rowing if you're going to chuck if
you're going to bet
on what boat is going to win and you
have no other information boat on
bet on the heaviest boat because the
heaviest boat
every between strokes the boat slows
down right because of friction with the
with the water right but if a heavier
boat it will slow down less
right and so no neil is exactly right if
if
if you treat the snow as a viscous
medium that's providing resistance to
your motion
you would want more mass but mostly most
of the time ski slopes are groomed
and so there isn't a lot of loose snow
blocking you so instead you're just
worried about the friction okay so it's
not an obvious clean answer there that's
right
and just to make it clear fat people
and skinny people will fall at the same
rate
free fall okay so it's not like you're
fat you'll fall faster than if you're
skinny
okay that's why that's why i'm on the
galileo diet because i
[Laughter]
all right guys we got to call it chris
here we should do this again this this
is fun and people are totally
in it from our fan base uh charles lew
always it's great to have you thank you
so much for having me it was such a
pleasure
it's great to see you guys and we love
your your covid rockstar hair yeah
thank you hey next time maybe we'll have
even more of it to discuss
yeah but then we're going to start a
band or something gary uh
always good and you're a good supporter
when i make when i make fun of your
vintage
hey look it is what it is dude we're
going to carbon date me as soon as these
moments we'll do that
we'll report that on the next episode
chuck knight always good to have you oh
it's a pleasure
i'm neil degrasse tyson as always to
keep
[Music]
you